well I think the government needs to get
around the table with the unions and
resolve this matter I don't think kind
of inflaming this situation is going to
abort the strikes and stop these strikes
from happening well her tone yeah I mean
her tone I think was a lot softer on on
your program uh earlier but clearly
she's being instructed uh by the Prime
Minister and others to to not discuss
pay to not have these negotiations in
any meaningful way and clearly they need
to happen because teachers are crying
out for a conversation they're crying
out to be heard they need supporting and
I think if we look back at kovid what
did we learn we learned that children
missing school is greatly damaging to
those young people I've got children
myself we can see the damage no one
wants to see strikes happening but I
think we also learn the value that
teachers bring and that how many of us
can't step in and become teachers to
show children overnight and children
need that face-to-face teaching so
that's why it needs proper negotiation
meaningful negotiation get round the
table stop these strikes from happening
because it's the last thing that parents
and children need it will cause a spiral
in inflation if all of these pay Rises
are agreed to by the government well
that's their opinion but what we've seen
over a long period of time it's not just
this year these these strikes haven't
just happened in the last few months
they've been brewing and brewing for a
long time because what we've seen is is
real terms pay cuts for our public
sector workers over a long period of
time you'll remember the George Osborne
David Cameron Coalition that came in and
pegged public sector pay at one percent
for it for a number of years and that
and they were sucked up at the time
because they were supposed to come a day
where the country could afford to pay
people properly and and now those same
public sector workers are being told
that the country can't can't afford to
pay them
issue though isn't it it's not just this
government it's a problem that the ha
the whole world is having to deal with
at the moment and that is off the back
of the pandemic that the government tell
us there just isn't any money well it is
there are some Global factors but but
the UK is is particularly exposed to
those the UK has been more affected by
some of these issues than most other uh
Western uh countries and we're not
seeing strikes public sector strikes uh
on the scale that we're seeing in this
country and in other places because I
think we we've seen a strategy over
recent months of the government to
almost goad some of these strikes we've
seen a little bit of change in tone uh
more recently but but you know the only
way that that industrial action and
these kind of disputes gets resolved is
whenever everybody gets around the table
and finds a way a way forward to it so
you if the education secretary is not
discussing uh the one issue that that
the unions want to discuss with her then
they're not going to get resolved are
they
um
Online safety Bill your opposite number
the culture secretary are going to
toughen up the Online safety Bill and
make social media bosses criminally
liable for failing to protect children
I'm guessing you're going to say about
time absolutely about time it's
something that we have been calling for
in fact we voted on a number of times
over the last few months in the House of
Commons but we do have to remember that
this very recent strengthening that's we
were hearing about overnight which the
government have been forced into doing
after uh Rebellion or a rebellion
Brewing on their own side comes after
they really watered down this bill
before Christmas so these criminal
sanctions are welcome we want the
regulator to have the teeth to really go
after some of these big tech companies
that are global companies but the scope
of the criminal sanctions is now a lot
narrower because the scope of the bill
is much narrower so it's only really
going to be about protecting Children
online not many of the other harms that
we see in social media and online like
disinformation misogyny racist abuse and
all of these challenges that we face as
a society and as a country do you think
the Prime Minister was right to block
block this latest
draft law by the Scottish government
when it came comes to gender ID well
look this we don't need to be here when
it comes uh to this issue the last thing
we need is an issue like this becoming
the uh the products of a bond fight
essentially a political posturing
between the Scottish nationalist
government and the UK government we
didn't need to end up here the Scottish
secretary I think we're not we don't
know exactly what he's going to say
today we don't know what legal advice
they've had but he seemed to suggest
that there was a bill that the
government could have lived with that
wouldn't have been in conflict with UK
equalities legislation well if that's
the case why wasn't the government in
the UK talking to the Scottish
government over many of the previous
months to resolve this before we even
got to to this point so we don't want to
see this being turned into a big
Constitution institutional route a big
standoff between the Scottish government
and the UK government we want a law that
that protects people's trans rights that
protects women's rights and that doesn't
create these kind of cross-border sort
of bureaucratic difficult issues about
how laws apply in in one country to
another it could have been resolved
before now and we hope it still can be
your leader says that 16 is too young
for someone to decide whether they
should be able to legally change their
gender or not the education secretary
said to me in the last hour that it's
not she thinks that 16 is the right age
what do you think well I think these
these issues people have their own views
about about that well I think it's it
you know these are complicated issues
but I totally respect uh kirst Armor's
view on on that and and other people's
views but I think this is a lot bigger
than that this particular issue that
we're now facing because it is a a
constitutional uh crisis a
constitutional matter and let's not
forget that well look I think I think
the labor party we brought in the gender
recognition act in the first place we
also brought in the equalities act we
also brought in the Scottish Parliament
and the Scottish act that gave rise to
these powers that the Secretary of
State's using today we never wanted to
see this situation that's not what all
of those those big progress that we made
as a party for this country in these
areas we didn't want to see them being
reduced in this way to a to a
constitutional route so you're not going
to give me a a yes or no on that but I'm
sure you'll have a view on this
metropolitan police officer David
Carrick who has admitted 49 charges
including 24 counts of rape over 17
years how on Earth could he still have
been imposed to that whole length of
time well these are the questions that I
think rightly uh are being asked what an
appalling awful uh case uh this is and I
want to pay tribute to the women who
came forward and ensured that eventually
this guy was held to account and has
been found guilty for for a huge number
over a long period of time of of rapes
and and sexual uh misconduct and abuse
and how he was able to use his his role
in the the police force as a cover as a
way of being able to get away with these
crimes you know these are the big
questions that are being asked and I
think we're we're right two years after
well more than two years after the awful
case of Sarah reverard which was has got
many of the same Hallmarks we find that
there's this other case that at the time
he wasn't even suspended at the time
even after Sarah everard when these very
serious allegations uh he was facing so
there are some big questions here we
were promised two or three years ago
that we would have uh new actions in
terms of police misconduct in terms of
vetting police vetting and these
processes the government said they were
going to bring them in after Sarah
revvard case and we're still awaiting
them so I think women and others across
the country will be rightly asking how
this continue to happen this continued
to happen even after the Sarah River rod
case how can
people who live in one of the biggest
cities in the world and tourists that
come to one of the biggest and most
popular cities in the world have faith
in a police force when this sort of
thing happens well there are serious
serious questions I think for the for
the Metropolitan Police and some of
these issues are being looked at by an
independent inquiry which I think could
be extended to to look at this this
current case they're obviously trying to
to root this out but I think what we
need is is more enforceable
laws and guidance tougher action that's
what labor said we will do to ensure
that there are consistent and clear
processes around how serious allegations
are dealt with that they should involve
immediate suspension and immediate
taking off off the beat in these sorts
of cases we need to have much clearer
vetting regime that is nationally
applied and clearly understood because
we've got to get some restore some trust
and accountability into our police force
as you say so that people people can
feel that they are being safe and looked
after in our capital city